well hello and welcome
I don't know if it's morning or
afternoon or evening or night time at
the time that you are watching this
program but we welcome you and we are
very excited to have you here with us
today I love The Smiling Faces so if
you're not smiling please smile
thanks Jenny
um everybody you are you're tuning in to
ask Vet Live today so I'm excited to see
new names new faces as I know that so
many of us
spin
more money
on our fur babies than we do on
ourselves
but we need to not forget who's taking
care of those for our babies but I'm so
excited
um that we're able to offer this show
and this is by popular demand I've had
so many people asking pet questions
that I'm like well why not just have a
show
with pet questions
asking
I don't know any other individual man
researcher veterinarian that has done as
much research not just in his own
Community but around the world
on animals and how the different
environmental things whether it's their
food whether it's the air
whether it's
I don't know how many different things
Dr Wallach can affect
human animal life sorry don't don't
forget competitors
I'm sorry competitors competitors
for food for space
that's right that's right I mean there's
this whole circle of life and whenever
there's an interruption in that circle
of life especially when it comes to
nutrients
because they're not all equal in the
ground that the food is grown in
we're going to have changes in how our
genes are expressed and my name is
Rebecca Dukes Kozak I am so excited to
be the host of today's program ask that
live I am joined with my lovely co-host
Ruth Ellen Sanchez Dr Judy Reynolds and
Heather Bowen and if you're on live with
us make sure that you have that chat on
if you don't know where to find the chat
go to the zoom menu
and click on chat
you'll be able to see all of the
information that they will be sharing in
the chat with us today in regards to
how products are named how they're
spelled different things that Dr Wallach
is going to be mentioning because he
does speak pretty fast
tell you what he's hard to keep up with
um so we want to make sure that you're
getting all the information and you can
also go to our website yes ask that
live.com and you will find the replay of
today's program and we've actually put
all the stock Live program replays on
there as well
so we have lots of questions coming in
through email through text message
through chat here today with us already
so thank you everyone for bringing those
questions
and again
I don't know a better person to be able
to be able
to host
on a show like this
the gentleman that we have with us today
and many of you know I'm you've heard
about him but his very first publication
was back in 1965 when he was a
Veterinary student and
there was a farmer that lost a ton of
lambs like 500 lambs and while everybody
else was on vacation
he was put in charge of this research
program
that
was just the beginning of the greatness
that he has been able to do now as a
veterinarian Dr wallach's career has
taken him to zoos and Wildlife areas
around the world treating Reese's
monkeys Lambs green iguanas rabbits
guinea pigs white rhinos Black Rhinos
wildebeest alligators gorillas elephants
giraffes camels other primates a
waterfowl game birds exotic birds
kangaroos ibics goldfish
what's a what's a penita panita pad Dr
Wallach
pinnipede
or or a goo noun
I mean these are things that you have
written research papers on over the
years and he's also done research with
manatees folks
manatees are
they look to be nice and calm and just
chill out pets not Pets the manatee is
hardly a pet yeah
a water mammal
but all of your research Doctor well
like has led to
a National Treasure
that National Treasure being the
diseases of exotic animals medical and
surgical management
that was published in 1983 and is today
held in the Smithsonian as a National
Treasure
now Dr well like when this book first
came out what was there 90
published
and so yeah yeah the first public yeah
they published 90 000 at first and so
like in 90 days and they were selling at
25 000 each
and um it represented uh a 10-year study
and I did 20 000 autopsies seventeen
thousand some change of over 454 species
of animals in three thousand humans
and um
it was very revealing information and
what it revealed was it didn't matter if
you were an odad which is kind of like a
wild goat or an elephant or lion tiger a
bear
um you could all have arthritis you
could all have congestive heart failure
it could all have asthma you could all
have psoriasis you don't have arthritis
I could also all have appendicitis and
so forth uh it didn't matter if you were
a reptile or a mammal or a fish a bird
it didn't matter if you had the organ if
you had intestines you could all get the
same problems and so these are the sort
of things that were very revealing and
um
the grant was a 25 million dollar Grant
was gotten when I was off in Africa
working on the White Rhino conservation
project
um Marlon Perkins and
um Barry Comet or the head of the
Department of biology
took my paper on the mass die off and
those Lambs were 500 died in one night
and I figured out that was due to a
pollution thing and it was the first
major publication on a pollution mass
time off in America okay and um it took
that and got this 25 million dollar
Grant from NIH and the whole idea was to
find animal species in zoos and wild
animal parks that were sensitive to
pollution and we're going to use them as
the equivalent of the canary in the mine
the old coal miners for hundreds of
years
maybe thousands of years had taken
canaries down in the coal mines and so
if gases would come into the mine the
canaries would drop off the perch and
die and the men knew to get out to save
themselves and so that was the whole
idea of doing all this pathology and
zoos we're looking for animals in zoos
in the big cities around the world that
were sensitive to the same pollutants
that humans were and if these animals
were to get sick or Die the population
would know to get up and get out and so
it was the whole idea of that study
and it blew their minds
um when the data started coming in
and of course it was a big project and
it lasted 10 years
and
um we're actually having it uh reprinted
right now as we speak
I think because of technology and
everything it'll be a little cheaper now
maybe much cheaper than twenty five
thousand dollars each
um you can get them sort of beat up used
online for
thirteen hundred fifteen hundred two
thousand dollars a lot of you know bent
pages and cover ripped off and all this
kind of stuff and then in fair condition
you can get them for five thousand eight
thousand dollars in good condition you
get them from six thousand to ten
thousand but after that it gets up and
they're into the big cost
and um it was that was a Hallmark study
it was a Hallmark study and I'm just
blessed to be the one chosen to do that
and
um Marlon Perkins I had worked with him
for many many years and he knew me and
when he got that paper
on that mass die off from collusion he
looked at that and he says well yeah
that'll be Wallach because I had worked
with him for so many years at the St
Louis Zoo anything he wanted done he
would come to me and it got done
and so he knew that um uh this was a
very very unique study
and
um uh he he and Barry commoner from
Washington University St Louis and
Barnes Hospital that whole team put that
Grant application together they got it
and they called me back from Africa
after two years of working there on the
White Rhino project and by the way back
then there was um a 300 White Rhino and
the unflossians Louis game reserves into
tell South Africa today there's 21 000
because we set up while the animal parks
to defend and protect the White Rhino so
we were very successful went from 300 to
000 so we're so grateful that all of
that happened and of course the book
um is still sells his kids love to read
the story of rhino Express this is the
story of those two years I spent in
Africa doing the White Rhino
conservation project and of course in
the book
the not only is it written material so
it's got a pictorial so that you
understand the process we're going
through to catch
uh 200 White Rhino and ship them to the
United States this was not it was not a
simple project
um we were using drugs over 10 000 times
more potent than morphine that way we
could get them into darts the size of a
triple a battery as opposed to darts the
size of a flashlight so
um we were changing everything because
of those drugs
etorphine 10 000 times more potent than
morphine and it had an antidote you
could give in the Rhino's ear vein and
wake them up when you want to wake him
up okay there you go the dart uh you see
it's the size of a triple a battery and
the whole project
um was we're learning as we're going
along here and creating the answers to
questions as we were going along so it
taught me a lot and I had lots of help
and it was I I can't tell you how
gracious
um
uh I I felt towards these teams of
people who were out there risking their
lives as saved as one species of animals
so it was really a great deal
well Dr well like I I want to point out
when people's like think about you know
capturing an animal and taking it out of
its natural environment to save it I've
had people email in it's like well
what happens to the animals that are
there or why are you taking them out of
their natural environment to save them
but people don't realize
during this whole process you are
creating reserves that's correct
so share with us a little bit about what
went into
those preserves what you were doing to
re-establish an environment that would
sustain the White Rhino that had been
dying off okay well they weren't dying
off they were targeted by the
um they were targeted by the native
populations for their horns which is
supposed to be
one of these drugs that helps your
sexual things going right and so they
would kill a rhino and just leave the
body there for the vultures eaten and
saw the horn often sell it for a lot of
money you know like a thousand dollars
an ounce okay
um it's because it's supposed to be one
of those drugs that helps you with your
sexuality and so forth and so that's you
know it was before all the drugs we have
now so that was the drug at the time for
sexuality was Rhino horn
and and so we interrupted that process
because there's only 300 left
and so we we took them out of that
environment so we could save them and
protect them and
um we
um about five years later we began to
put them back but then by then we had
the reserves that we had instituted and
built and they had all the South
Africans had come up with all of the
um uh
the
the guys were sort of like policemen for
the reserves okay they were they were
there to protect the White Rhino but we
we didn't have all that when I first
went there I mean I went there I'm
living out in the bush there was death
out there except rhinos and vultures and
me okay
and so it was quite interesting and I
was shot at many times unfortunately
never hit
um but um
is one of those things
to understand the ecology and what was
going on there what it took and what it
took to catch a white rhino and keep it
alive we had to keep it alive for I
would say
um four to six to eight weeks
in a box
because we had to put them on a ship we
had to put him on a ship for two to four
weeks so they had to learn to live in
that box continuously and we'd clean up
their manure out of the back end of the
Box we'd feed them water and food from
the front end of the box and once they
were comfortable with that and they were
sleeping and not banging around in the
box trying to get out and they were
quite comfortable with it then we knew
we could ship them
to America to save them
okay and so that that's why it took two
years to save 200 of them because it
took anywhere from uh six to eight weeks
to train them to live uh and be
comfortable in those boxes and it shows
the pictures
um of those boxes in the book okay and
Rhino Express
there you go and that's where those
Rhino had to live for two to four weeks
on those ships going across the ocean
and they you know they were comfortable
with that they were getting fed and
watered and so they were quite
comfortable probably getting more food
than they had been when they're out on
their own
well I personally like Windows in my box
if you ever put me in a box stock okay
give me when we couldn't put Windows in
there because they would break the
windows or they would be scared uh and
not feel comfortable with this way they
were in a dark
um a container they could hear things
but they couldn't see anything
okay and after a while once they were
trained and they knew that's where they
got fed we could let them out into a
Corral and we'd ring a bell and they'd
go into their box we'd shut the door
behind them and then feed them and so
that's how the process went and so it
was kind of like ringing the bell for
the dairy cows to come in uh principal
gotcha wow well I didn't finish my
introduction but folks you are watching
ask that life
and if you were invited by somebody
specific make sure that you get back
with them
with what you would like because we have
many hands up I have many questions that
have been texted in uh we want to make
sure that we get your answers and yes we
will take human questions but if we
could save the human questions for the
end as we focus on our fur babies today
so
Dr Wallach let's go ahead and go right
into the first hand Christy
go ahead and unmute yourself as your
hand for a fur baby
hello Christy oh hello I didn't I'm
sorry
um thank you so much for taking this
call and for all the work you do Dr
Wallach I have a question
um I'm taking care of my sister's dog
he's a lovely dog he's a senior dog he's
15 and I don't I am not giving him his
pain meds this Grappa print it makes him
Moody and he falls all over the place so
I've been giving him white willow bark
but I heard that you have to I kind of
stopped on that because I heard that you
that could give him ulcers I'm going to
get him maybe some CBD tincture I don't
know what else you suggest
okay well is this because the pain is it
from arthritis yeah it's arthritis okay
okay well here's here's what I would do
oh you say the dog is uh 15 years old
how much does it weigh is it a little
dog 14
um he's going 14 going on 50. he weighs
about 28 between 28 and 37 pounds he
said he'd be a big dog if he had long
legs he's kind of stocky he's uh silly
anterior and shitsu and uh beagle okay
so it's a it's a mixed breed yeah and uh
28 pounds okay very mixed okay 28 pounds
okay well here's what I would do I would
get our
um
MSM okay okay and add it to the dog food
at 28 pounds I'd give them uh three of
those MSM tablets you may have to grind
them up and put them in the food mix
them in the food gotcha okay and then
also I would give them a scoop
of the
um let's see collagen peptides which is
um cartilage and tendons and ligaments
from fish poultry sheep and beef that's
going to help regrow cartilage and
tendons and ligaments even in a 15 year
old dog okay
I would also put in a couple of say two
vitamin D3 tablets
and for pain immediate pain you could
use our
CM cream just put a couple of dabs of
that on his hips or his stifles which is
our knees his feet his neck her
shoulders where everybody has pain uh
just put a couple of dabs or CM cream on
there and get a couple of hours of
significant pain relief
but it won't take long you'll see a
couple weeks two to four weeks uh all
that collagen and peptides you're given
I'm adding to them is going to
um rebuild everything even in a 15 year
old dog okay yeah he's he's kind of gets
grumpy when you touch him he's so in
pain so yeah you can try that okay
that's probably I think I don't think
that that drug is good for him I'm not
giving it to him but she's away right
now thank God yeah
okay
you bet it's a good nutritional approach
and all those all those products are on
your website
I'm sorry are all those products on your
website
okay absolutely okay yeah we have we
have 600 programs okay for for health
issues including arthritis and
osteoporosis and we have 5 000 products
there's no reason why our pets can't use
them just like we do okay thank you so
much thank you for your time God bless
you
all right thank you Christy and yes if
you go to well first if you were invited
to this program by somebody specific get
with them because chances are they have
a special website for you to order from
if you were not invited by anybody
specific you are welcome to go to RS dot
ask Vet Live and keep the program
straight ask
vetlive.com and you will find the store
there as well plus Dr wallach's books uh
we have a link there that takes you
through his most popular books uh with a
description and the ability to buy them
through the website as well well Dr
Wallach let's go to the next town that
is up and Tanya go ahead and unmute
yourself
thank you so much and thank you Dr
Wallach I've been using youngevity to to
help my animals for a while now and um I
do have a testimonial first off because
I my Joe got quite the the gash on his
forehead and you can't even see it
because I use Trinity cream on and it
was huge for keeping the Flies off and
we did that with our cows with pink eye
because that was bad this year and we
used colloidal silver and Trinity cream
to keep the flies off outside and it was
phenomenal so greatly appreciated thank
you well thank you for that testimony
oh absolutely
um so my question is we have beef cattle
and uh my mom was asking me about milk
fever if uh if a cow has milk fever what
can we do to prevent her from getting it
again is there a way that we can prevent
that yeah well milk fever has to do with
missing nutrients that are used to make
milk
okay
and so
um you know for large animals like
cattle of course we do have the
arthrodex it's one scoop for for small
animals is one scoop for 20 pounds of
body weight but when you when you get
into a beef cow a dairy cow it'd be say
one scoop for 50 to 100 pounds depending
you know if they're a jersey or Holstein
right okay and so
um uh yeah I would go with that
and
um you're going to see remarkable
results very very quickly
perfect thank you you're very very
welcome
Dr Wallach would you just sprinkle that
over there hey they're grain oh there
are three days no the arthradex is a
powder you're gonna have to mix it in
with the grain
uh you can't mix it in with the hay
because it'll just filter out to the
bottom you know off to the floor but
when you mix it in with their grain
um it'll you know stay with it okay
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
yeah Green is usually in a feed bucket
so that makes it easier for them to lick
the bottom up because I know exactly my
animals love it
um even the rabbit loves the Arthur
decks
let's go to the next town that is up and
Doug go ahead and unmute yourself
yeah can you hear me yes sir
got a question for you doc I weigh 138
pounds I'm 5 feet 6 inches tall I'm 79
years old my health concern is Becker's
dystrophy
okay now you have to tell me what is
Becker's dystrophy muscular dystrophy
the adult form of duches okay so okay MD
muscular dystrophy okay in fact um
that's one of the things I'm working on
right now is of course I'm the first one
to find the
um
cystic fibrosis in an animal in a
Yorkie's monkey in 1977.
and then of course we were
working on mustard this fee uh in
animals after dealing with the cystic
fibrosis
and Son of a death syndrome and we have
an enormous amount of experience in
those things so when you have muscular
dystrophy regardless of your age 138
pounds I would take two healthy brain
and heart packs for months two healthy
man heart patch per month photos filling
twice a day get two bottles of MSM so
you can take three at breakfast three at
lunch or dinner time they're going to
rebuild cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between a
vertebrae bone makes a bone itself put a
scoop of the collagen peptides in your
morning drink or smooth the collagen
peptide your evening drink take a scoop
in your morning drink and scoop your
evening drink of the of the um uh Beyond
Osteo FX I do that it's a powder and put
it in the drink very easily take vitamin
D three three of those twice a day and
if you have pain in your joints uh go
ahead and use the CM cream topically and
even at your age you're going to have a
rapid rebuilding of of your joints okay
okay thank you
all right thank you Doug yeah Doug was a
primate
oh well uh Dr Wally
I prefer human over primate and we're
all mammals right that's correct there
we go
all right there's a few snakes in the
bunch but you know
this this is true
the doctor well like I want to go to a
question that was emailed in and this is
email Dan Yesterday by Joe and I think
Joe is on the line with us today
yes Joe go ahead and unmute yourself
thank you can you hear me yes
um hi there I have three pup questions
I'll be quick
um one of them is for a friend she has
an 11 year old Chinese crested Powder
Puff male dog he has a sarcoma sarcoma
tumor on a spleen he's been given three
to six months to live and he is not
eating
and that's all I know okay well you know
these are very serious situations and of
course he's not eating uh what I want
you to do is just take the plant
minerals
and you say he weighed how much
she didn't tell me but he's small I'm
guessing he probably weighs 15 to 20
pounds okay then I would take a couple
of tablespoons or plant minerals just
unflavored liquid plant minerals and
wrote them on that dog twice a day
rub them on the dog yeah and we'll
absorb it through the skin
and I've seen miracles happen by
absorbing these minerals for the skin of
both humans and animals
so if he's not eating
rub it on the skin
whatever if he'll roll over on his back
and let you rub it on his belly fine
otherwise you may have to hold him you
know put put a headlock on him and have
somebody else and of course rub it with
the hair Direction don't rub it against
the grain on the hair but rub it with
the hair Direction
um
but if he'll let you rub it on his belly
that's fine
all right excellent what's your next
question Joe my next one is
um for my pup um
he is a his name is Barry he's a 74
pound four-year-old black golden doodle
80 poodle he's a tall sturdy dog
um he's always scratch
um he has to get shots from the vet to
help with scratches is it a he or a she
it's a he he's a boy and his scratching
is currently under control he has
chronic ear infections those are under
control at two years of age he had his
first um seizure he does a whole seizure
pre thing staring off the distance tucks
his tail vomits runs Falls seizes
paddles limbs Foams at the mouth
urinates last a minute or so and then he
has trouble walking he's had six to
seven of these in two years he's on
lebatracetime one pill three times a day
he prior to this he fell into the
shallow end of a pool two months before
the seizures began not sure if there's
correlation I feel there is
um he vomited after that had trouble
walking kind of had a twisted body and
then we drove nine hours home okay
so stop there okay you say he weighs 74
pounds yes all right okay so
um I want him to get most of his dog
food in the form of moist canned dog
food you know as opposed to dry dog food
these are if he's only eating dry dog
food now changes so half of it at least
is canned dog food
okay because I want you to mix I want
you to mix in that dog food or
arthroducts uh it's the one scoop for 20
pounds of body weights will be Four
Scoops the arthritax mixed in there and
I also want him to have a soft boiled
egg soft Wild
herself scrambles in butter
mix that in
I also wanted to have our arthrodex okay
go ahead and put in arthradex
um three of those twice a day and I also
wanted to have
um are synaptives take our synaptive for
the seizures and all that kind of stuff
uh take
um three of those are synaptics the raw
materials that the brain requires
to make the chemistry necessary for the
brain cells to talk to each other then
call US every couple of weeks because I
think you're going to see something very
interesting positive
okay um and so he has a lot of food
allergies but I'm just going to pretty
much ignore those and go with these
because we did a had a hair test on him
um and just to clarify you said four
scoops of um arthrodex and then you said
three arthroducts
also no no just just fine just it's um
Four Scoops of the arthroducts okay and
then the next question is for Finley
Rose this is my last one she's our
two-year-old golden doodle she's 46
Pounds she's a slight frame taller and
leggy she had her first set of vaccines
at five weeks old her second said at
seven weeks and was spayed at the same
time she has excessive itching
um I have her on a very clean dog food
but I just wanted to know what else we
can do to help her she also had a um
anal gland
um rupture
and that's better now okay good all
right
um well again uh because of the skin
issues I would add to the dog food that
says let's see here you say is
um
46 Pounds is that correct yes she is um
okay okay uh I'd give her two of the MSM
tablets ground up and put in the food to
MSM I'd also put one scoop of the
um collagen peptides and the dogs love
it because it's made from cartilage from
fish and poultry and sheep and beef so
they love that cartilage okay
and that's going to help with the skin
okay
already and do you think there's such a
thing as dogs having leaky gut also
well yeah if you're feeding that dog dog
food or straight table scraps or gluten
in it
um they're going to get all that gut
stuff irrele bowel syndrome like you got
all that kind of thing no gluten no
wheat nobody Ryan oats okay
yep it's the only the only people and
animals that are not sensitive to gluten
are dead people and dead animals
appreciate you thank you okay God bless
you too thank you
all right thank you so much Joe let's go
to the next town that is up Dr Wallach
and everybody thank you so much for
joining us here on ask that live if
you're on live with us you do have the
capability of raising your hand and
asking questions now today we're gonna
focus on our pets and I was gonna say
four-legged but some of our pets are not
always four-legged they're two-legged
and if they've had issues they might be
three or one-legged but anyways let's go
on to is it Joe is it Joanne or Johanna
and you should be able to unmute now
hi it's Joanne
well welcome thank you
um I have a two-year-old karat mix that
I rescued at 12 weeks he was healthy
Tiny But healthy and I brought him to
the vet to have him checked out and
tested for feline leukemia when I
brought him home and it was during covid
lockdown so I wasn't able to go in with
him and she accidentally gave him a
vaccination that he had just received
five days prior
and pretty much went downhill from there
he didn't get off the couch all day the
next day he couldn't breathe he was
sneezing coughing he had severe upper
respiratory infection I had to bring him
to the emergency room
he recovered from that but then started
developing what we thought was crystals
and he was treated for that it did not
resolve he was tested there is no
bacteria and the vet pretty much said
that it's stress induced but he doesn't
seem like a stressed cat he doesn't seem
like he's sick and so I had him checked
out by someone else who was just a
little bit more holistic and she feels
that he is vaccine damaged and has
inflammation as in his urethra from that
double vaccination
so I didn't know if there's something
that I can do to try and clear that or
if you have any other recommendations he
strains you know just about every day at
some point mostly what's about what's
the weight
he's about 13 pounds okay all right well
I'd give him um one scoop of Archer
decks okay per day I would also
um let's see here I would also give him
um of the
um
and it's primarily a urethra problem
right now you think yeah that's what the
Vets thinking some inflammation there
because he's straining like he thinks he
needs to go and it's always some form of
pink in his urine like he'll still get
out of his box and and then he'll strain
right outside his box again but then
he'll run off like a crazy Gap
okay all right
um again well I would you know give him
uh the um uh let's see here the
arthrodex but I would also give him MSM
at 13 pounds I just give him two the MSM
tablets Brian him up putting his food I
would also give him the ultimate daily
classic tablets I give him two the
ultimate daily class of Talis grind them
up and they're going to support healthy
blood flow through
the kidneys okay and the heart and the
Brain
and the liver and the muscles and the
research so let's go with those uh two
of the ultimate daily classic tablets a
day okay okay do you have a recommended
way to get them into an animal that
refuses to eat anything other than dry
food or freeze-dried broth that's it so
okay what you do okay what you do is you
moisten the dried food with some uh or
liquid minerals
and then mix in the
ground up tablets and if he doesn't eat
it just pick it up
and put in the ice box and then later in
the day moisten it again
okay and after about the third day he'll
eat it okay the Orthodoxy has no problem
I can put that powder on the floor and
it'll lick it right up okay good
okay awesome thank you so much God bless
you did
all right thank you Joanne
uh Dr Wallach let's just move right into
the next stand that is up and Phyllis
go ahead and unmute you are on live with
Dr wallacon ask about live
good morning doc good morning I love
hearing your animal stories and I know
you especially love the large exotic
animals
uh we have a nine-year-old Maine
female cat we've had her for a year and
she's always been small
uh she just saw the dead because she was
constipated
um she gets mostly wet food gluten free
a little bit of gluten-free kibble good
appetite
um she the vet recommended uh Miralax
daily and and that has cleared up for
constipation but two issues
um one he said she was underweight she's
6.7 pounds
and uh number two frequent hair balls we
try to keep her brushed and trim up her
fur but we're wondering what we can do
about the underweight and the hair balls
okay I would um scramble
some eggs and some butter and mix that
with the food
okay some scrambled eggs
and then
um
they hear when they have hairballs it
usually happens because they have
mineral deficiencies they're licking
licking licking licking kind of thing
creating the hairballs and so
um what needs to happen here is put an
ounce of our liquid plant minerals into
say six ounces of water
and put that in the cats you know just
make that the Camp's water source so put
it in a bowl and the the cat will drink
that water with the minerals in it
okay you think they'll drink it oh yeah
perfect keep the lid down on the toilet
they don't drink out of the toilet thank
goodness okay okay good
all right thank you Dr Wallach new bed
all right thank you Phyllis and Doc
let's just keep going so Tamara rose has
a question she actually has three
questions
and
first one a dog 15 pounds
Jack Russell 11 years old
and just started with incontinence
issues
um and says on quarter pro-in now I
don't know if that's a pharmaceutical
for pets or not
um but let me see if she is on with us
but what would you recommend for a 15
pound dog with incontinence Dr Wallach
okay this could be due to several things
um do we know how old this dog is 11
years old 11 years old yeah well the dog
could have some osteoporosis okay where
the
and I apologize is this a male or female
hmm
okay
okay female okay
female okay yeah all right okay so
um again this dog needs to have 15
pounds one scoop of arthro decks uh in
the food
and um put the minerals the liquid
minerals you know one ounce into say
five or six ounces of water in the bowl
on the ground okay so he gets the liquid
minerals that way and then
um let's see here
um
did do we cover everything
so we've got the arthroducts we've got
the liquid minerals
was there something but the dog is okay
the dog is incontinent could have
osteoporosis of the skull okay squeezing
the spinal cord and his spinal cord is
telling the urinary bladder to urinate
just like it does in humans people get
up five six eight ten times a night to
urinate when they have osteoporosis it's
called squeezing the spinal cord
and so it's gonna be a little bit of
that going on and so again don't forget
the uh collagen peptides at 15 pounds I
would throw in a half a scoop okay in in
the dog food dogs will love it because
it's made out of cartilage and ligaments
and tendons and connective tissue I
would also throw in uh two tablets of
MSM grind them up put that powder in
there because we want to rebuild the
dog's skull you want to rebuild the dogs
cervical vertebrates which could be
squeezing the spinal cord which is
causing the urinary bladder to urinate
all right and so Tamara's next question
is also a dog
eight years old nine pounds
just removed a huge oxalate Stone
um the pup is half is a Chihuahua cross
and for years was having blood in the
urine and urinary tract infections until
they discovered the bladder stone
okay well kidney stones bladder stones
are caused by
mineral deficiencies okay when the body
starts robbing the bones out of minerals
trying to raise the blood level of
minerals
and so it kind of overcompensates and
that's why they get kidney stones
bladder stones all that kind of stuff
um it's not from too much minerals it's
from not enough minerals
so this dog at nine pounds needs a half
a scoop of our of the arthrodeculus food
every day okay arthrodex
um needs the collagen peptides I'd go
with a half a scoop
the collagen peptides in the food and I
I would also go with two of the MSM
tablets ground up and put in the food
all right thank you so much and
um Tamara I hope that you were listening
whenever doc was talking about arthritis
because I know her third question had to
do with a 10 year old terrier mix
uh 19 pounds with arthritis so duck if
you wouldn't mind going over what you
would give a 19 pound dog for arthritis
again that would be fabulous okay well
again I prefer canned dog food because
you can mix stuff in it and the dog
can't separate it okay but 19 pounds is
one scoop of the arthrodex mixed in the
dog's food the dog also needs
um uh two MSM tablets okay
and let's see here
um mixed in I would also throw in and
this is this is uh causing
um arthritis arthritis okay yeah the MSM
uh uh two of those tablets ground up I
would also throw in the vitamin D3 one
or two of those in the dog food and it
wouldn't hurt again it's throwing the
collagen peptides a half a scoop at
breakfast half scoop at dinner time
twice a day
now Dr Wallach um she brings up a a
really good point or she brings up the
fact that all of the dogs are on a ride
a raw diet now you're mentioning canned
diet why would you recommend
a canned formula over a raw diet
because raw diet you have not worth the
idea how many minerals are in there
nutritional minerals do not occur in a
uniform blanked around the coast of the
earth they turn veins like gold and
silver some might only have two minerals
the 1936 he was in a document 264 said
we don't have enough nutritional Metals
in our soil anymore
okay and so it might only have three
minerals in there it's the only way
you're going to guarantee the minerals
is with the arthrodex
okay and uh the MSM and the collagen
peptides
and um dry dogs or or raw dog food okay
um it just won't cut it you're expecting
to be all the nutrients in there and as
they say in France it ain't happening
well Dr Wallach basically it's the same
as as our human food supply that's
correct right that's why we have trouble
with humans food that's why we have
trouble with human disease
and even if you know for those of us
that are meat eaters if
the animals that we then eventually have
on our plate are not getting the
nutrients that they need to be healthy
they're not able to pass that nutrition
on to us either
it is correct meat isn't it meat in
itself is not a perfect food if all you
eat is meat you're going to be very sick
within a couple of months
um from you know a balance problem
because meat has certain nutrients in it
but it doesn't have all 90. and so
you're just begging for trouble
when you go that direction
I agree it's kind of like putting it's
kind of like putting dirt from Texas in
your car
come on there's bound to be some oil in
it there's bound to be some gasoline in
there that's dirt from Texas
now an idiot
wouldn't do that to their car
when people say well I'm just going to
be a vegetarian and just eat vegetables
okay well
um you're begging for trouble
if you want to be a vegetarian you have
to take all 90 essential nutrients
according to your body weight Faithfully
every day
because if you're a vegetarian
and you're not getting all 90 essential
nutrients in in your
in your walnuts and your
and your onions and and your tomatoes
that kind of stuff which you won't
okay because plants do not make minerals
they only need three they only need mpk
when you look at commercial fertilizers
they only contain NPK so that's all the
plant needs to give the form of the
maximum yield in terms of tons of
breaker now you tell me uh Rebecca does
a farmer get paid by tons and bushels or
does a farmer get paid by how much
nutrition's in the food
it's by the it's by the ton in bushel
doc there you go so he goes for the NPK
because it's cheap
and it gives them the tons and bushels
yeah but then he gives all his animals
he's feeding that hay too he gives all
them the 90 essential nutrients
well I think
everybody everything that breathes right
everything that breathes needs the 90
essential nutrients that is correct
whether you're a bird a reptile a mammal
um a Pisco fish it doesn't matter all
living animals including humans require
the 90 steps of nutrients
all right so Dr Wallach let's go ahead
and go to Elaine who has her hand up
here before we get our break Elaine go
ahead and unmute yourself
you're on live with Dr Wallach do you
have a pet question today
um well I do
um and hi Dr Wallach I've followed you
for more than 20 years wow
um
now I feed a raw food diet it's a high
quality Frozen it is muscle meat organ
meat ground bone uh sometimes I I like
to stick with beef I don't
Trail off too much more than that
um should I be adding added minerals as
you're saying now
you need to be adding on top of that the
arthrodex one scoop for 20 pounds of
body weight
um and say for 20 pounds of body weight
I would throw in one or two of the MSM
okay and then of course uh don't forget
the collagen peptides don't forget D3
and so um you know uh eating whole meat
you know for instance like eating
chicken and you give them the bones and
dogs eat the cartilage off the ends of
the bones and eat the bones and sit
there and crunch the bones and things
they're getting more nutritionists than
if they're just getting the meat but
it's still not perfect
okay
yeah I
throw out um
beef neck bones occasionally out in the
yard and let them chew on those for a
bit but I just wondered if I needed to
be putting something else on there there
one is ten one is nine I've been feeding
them for about nine years on that and
I've never had any health issues I have
some vets that aren't for it but yeah
well anytime you're feeding bones to
meeting animals you're getting minerals
okay and so there's bound to be some
calcium and phosphorus and magnesium
there's bound to be some zinc and stuff
like that but you know how much iodines
in there how much
um
uh sulfur is in the bones as if they
don't have the cartilage there and so
these are the sort of things that you
get away with it for a long time when
you're when you're doing more things
other than just giving meat and you're
giving the bones and stuff like that
you're gonna you know you're gonna add
25 to 30 more time for them but if you
give them all 90
um instead of them living to be happily
12 15 years old amazing live to be
um 25 to 30 years of age
wow God bless your work thank you so
much for your time today
well you're very welcome thank you all
right thank you Elaine
now Dr Wallach there's there's a lot of
questions in regards to
uh oh where'd you go
I'm here where are you I'm trying to
find myself there we are I see you
I love technology when everything's
bouncing around and you're trying to hit
the right button and it moves on you
because people are popping in and out
it's just fantastic
um so I and that just makes me
appreciate my co-hosts more and more Dr
Wallach
I do I do
well
so
arthrodex let's talk about arthrodex
because arthrodex you have been
recommending four cats for dogs four
Birds four cattle
tell us about arthrodex that makes it so
versatile
well it covers a lot of territories as
far as a number of minerals in there and
it's in a powdered form granule farm so
that you can mix it in any type of food
and it's kind of like
um when you have a carnivore you know
whether they're a lion tiger or a bear
kind of thing or a dog or a coyote kind
of thing
um
there's certain things they will eat
okay and because they're familiar with
it they're designed
okay to eat those things they're not
going to eat sliced bread very often
it's not going to be a major part of
their meal
okay it's not going to satisfy their
craving for meat and bones and that kind
of stuff
well I know for me if I start eating
bread that has gluten I can't stop
eating and I think that was probably one
of my
biggest issues and I find with my dogs
too when I have them on a food that has
gluten in it they're eating all day long
but when I put the arthrodex on a
gluten-free food they'll stop they'll
have some bites and then they're on
their way
and they're active and and they're not
sluggish
it's amazing the difference in just
changing out
that key component within a food
and then yeah
the only people and the only animals
that are not sensitive to gluten or dead
animals and dead people
and as Phyllis Phyllis mentioned
feed for the 90 essential nutrients
expires when your need for oxygen oxygen
expires very well said
Very Yes Phyllis thank you so much
and it's not it's the animal world and
the human world it's amazing how many
things
cross over
and are applicable to both
so I
well we're made from the same
um
what should I say same design we're made
from the same design you go back to the
beginning of history when the good Lord
made the Earth and all the critters on
Earth and everything like that
um were made from the same
raw materials
and um
it's kind of interesting you know which
one
um the good Lord started with the good
Lord started with trilobites
and then went to dinosaurs we came along
a lot later we weren't first in line
we were kind of the afterthought that's
correct I think yeah
I don't want to say that he got bored
with the things that didn't talk back
but
okay and the Garden of Eden how much
weight did the Garden of Eden have
I don't know that it really talks about
wheat well it doesn't have any Wheat the
only thing in the Garden of Eden was
herbs and fruit treats
is very well described in the Old
Testament okay is herbs and fruit trees
okay
there was no wheat products there were
no wheat Brown rhinos there was no corn
there were no potatoes there was none of
that kind of stuff which is herbs and
fruit treats
wow
to a question that Therese has Dr
Wallach her question is are there any
fruits or vegetables
that are
that can be added to canned dog food
that would make it's just are there
fruits and vegetables healthy for dogs
as well
well as far as just you know you know
you want to add some um
um corn is probably safe you want to add
some rice it's safe
um
you want to add some onions it's okay
but you know what's in it besides some
carbohydrates and some flavor why do you
want to put that stuff in in the dog
food and the cat food
is because you like it and you think
it's going to be a treat for the animal
well they may like it from a treat
standpoint but again how many minerals
are in there 3 5 18 25 you don't know
and so you can't use that as a way to
say well I'm giving them stuff I get
people all the time when I talk to them
I say well do you supplement well yeah I
supplement I've been supplementing my
whole life okay well what do you
supplement with well I take vitamin C
but what else you take nothing I just
take Vitamin C but I eat well
well that's why you have 18 diseases
you're you've had a double knee
replacement
and you have all your teeth are gone and
you have implants okay because you're
not doing everything right
gotcha
all right well I can't believe our first
hour is already up let's go ahead and
take a quick five minute break Dr
Wallach okay and we will be right back
with ask that live thank you so much
everybody for joining us here on ask
that live and
oh lots of great questions
so I know we spend a lot of time uh with
our fur babies we want to make sure
because they can't really take care of
themselves
that we're taking good care of them and
being responsible pet owners
let's not forget about ourselves because
if there's nobody there to take care of
your pet babies
who's going to take care of them so
making sure that you're taking care of
yourself as well is very very important
folks but we will be right back after
this short break on ask that live
remember if you have a question that you
would like to ask Dr Wallach in regards
to your pet's health
go ahead and raise your hand if you are
on live with us go to that Zoom menu
click on reactions you'll find the
option to raise hand there
if you are watching the replay
get back with the person that invited
you to watch that replay and say hey
this doctor was talking about some
situations that I have going on with my
little fur babies
I need to get what he recommended
and they will have a special way to
order if you were not recommended by
anybody specific then feel free to go to
ask Vet Live
that's v-e-t ask
vetlive.com and we have a store there on
ask that live now
I know that this time does not work for
everybody but there are lots of
opportunities that you are able to ask
your questions of Dr Wallach and one of
our programs that's been going the
longest I think it was one of the very
original programs is on the radio on
ksco.com you can do the live stream and
from 12 to 1 Dr Wallach is on answering
questions for folks that are calling
into the station in regards to their own
health and what they can do to help
improve themselves physically medically
you know but I do want to rec uh remind
everybody that this program is brought
to you for informational purposes only
it is not intended to take the place of
a primary care physician or veterinarian
but
from my personal experience
the medical system failed me
and since we have a world-renowned
veterinarian with us today I think that
his experiences constitutes
um opening up our ears listening and
implementing what he's recommending
because he's been doing this for over 50
years folks
it's I think it's 60 years wow he's 83
years old and his first publication was
in his early 20s when he was just a
veterinarian student
so he's got a little bit of experience a
little bit of knowledge he's been asked
to do some major research programs I
think that the words coming out of his
mouth have a little bit of credibility
don't know about you
but Dr Wallach will be back with us in
just a moment we have more questions
coming in greatly appreciate all the
questions because
I'm sure you're not the only one with
that question
and when people are asking questions on
this recorded program we are able to
then
share it through video replays that then
makes stronger communities both in our
animal world and in our human world
so here let me see
I've got lots of questions coming in
Dr Wallace there's Dr Wallach we're back
back with us here in just a moment so
welcome back Dr Wallach
now um Jenny's mother-in-law says that
dogs can't eat red onions
are there are there specific foods that
animals should not be fed or given
if a human being can eat it an animal
can eat it
how about chocolate
oh they love chocolate
okay
because there's this thing that says
don't give dogs chocolate it's bad for
them
and I have a grandfather who had a dog
named Snickers who got at least one Fun
Size Snicker a day and snicker
lived till he was 22 years old well
there you go
chocolate will extend your dog's life to
22 years
I don't know about all that Sugar though
doc
well it lived 22 years that's pretty
good yeah let's see what is one year in
dog life is to how much in humans
seven seven so 22 is 14 14 it's 154
years
that's a long life for anybody but I
plan on living I'm gonna eat more
chocolate
okay thanks okay I'm adding it I'm
adding it to my diet doc thank you so
much I think there's other people
that'll appreciate that but we do want
to make sure that we're eating quality
chocolate oh yeah and so when it comes
available folks the youngevity has some
amazing chocolate unfortunately it does
not ship
in the warmer months
um and even in San Diego in the warmer
months I cannot pick it up
that just breaks my heart
but that's all part of planning and
making sure that we have what we need
available on our shelves for ourselves
and our pets for multiple months it's
correct because the supply train pickups
we have going on right now uh I I like
to keep a three-month supply of
everything
yes at least
I personally like six just well there
you go
I don't know overachiever I don't know
um but Kyrie comes on and she's like
um I board dogs I use the what the ygy
that's youngevity calming spray
to have nice downtime during the day and
keep their anxiety and excitement in a
new place abated that's a really good
recommendation Carrie thank you so much
for bringing that up
so the calming spray is
just some essential oils that are pet
safe that's been mixed into
a spray and I've actually used it with
my dogs when we're traveling
they get a little carsick
not a little Rottweilers get really
effective
but I spray a little bit on my hand and
then I rub the inside of their ears with
it and it doesn't take much I could even
put it on my hands and then just put it
up close to their muzzle let them smell
it
and that whole you know drooling and out
the nose out the window because they
can't seem to get enough and then they
got to get out
it's definitely reduced so I appreciate
the calming spray thank you so much for
care for bringing that up Carrie
um and
hey Dan at the end of the show so give
us another 35 minutes raise your hand
and we will get to some human questions
let's let's make sure that we get the
human questions
let's go ahead and go to Carrie she
doesn't have video but she does have a
question for you doc so okay Jerry go
ahead and unmute yourself
you're online with Dr Wallach
hi Dr Wallach can you hear me yes ma'am
oh yes great
um I had a bottle of the white Osteo
effects that broke in the mail and the
company took care of all of that we've
handled all of that but I still have
this bottle and I was just wondering if
it's something that can be used either
in the garden like around citrus tree or
avocado trees or if it can be used uh
for pets
okay well I'd filter it to make sure
there's no particles of glass in there
or if you want to if you have fruit
trees you just dig a hole say 10 feet
away from the trunk of the fruit tree
and just bury it and the fruit tree will
be getting some of that
okay
so it is good for use in the garden and
oh yeah oh absolutely
but probably not pets
well again I'd filter it to make sure
there's no glass particles or anything
like that in there
okay
yeah it was plastic it was the the lid
just broke off I the mailman dropped it
instead of setting it so okay thank you
I really I was really more interested in
using it in the garden I feel like in
calories don't waste it don't waste it
yeah yeah I don't want to waste it
exactly okay thank you you bet
all right thank you Carrie that's a
great question and I know Dr Wallach
whenever my vitamins or anything drop on
the ground because I have pets it's not
one of those five second rules
where you just pick it up blow it off
and then take it
um I throw them out in the garden it
doesn't matter what they are or I give
them to my pet if it's Fallen where
they're the ones making the mess
um
but let's talk about
essential fatty acids Dr Wallach and the
importance of essential fatty acids for
our pets as well
okay well essential fatty acids as the
name implies are required essential okay
to life in health
and um they are required for skin health
for intestinal health for Respiratory
Health
they've helped reduce the risk of blood
clots and strokes and all that kind of
stuff
so
um I take three of the efas and three of
the fa pluses twice a day
okay and
um I weigh 142 pounds I'm probably
overdoing it you could probably get away
with half of that say three
of each twice a day
okay sweet breakfast through dinner time
okay
but I take a lot so
so
just Dr well like the essential fatty
acids yes they're essential they're
needed what specific functions of the
body
are they most important for
well they have multiple functions they
prevent
um abnormal blood clots
they um support healthy respiratory
function
they help with skin health
they help with brain function everything
from memory to
um
sex hormones and all that kind of stuff
cfas are
really essential
okay as opposed to something you rub on
you know like a cosmetic thing
right because it's working at the
cellular level
from the inside out that's correct
so I have had pets in the past Dr
willick that their skin was so itchy
they scratched all the time
I did two things I got rid out of rid of
gluten from their diets
and I added essential fatty acids and
that might happen
are they no longer scratched isn't that
amazing
simple
it was simple
I think that we make it complicated Dr
Wallace and when you do that you're
adding many healthful years to a dog's
life
so it's not only a cosmetic and a sort
of
um
lifestyle benefit but also you're adding
many household years to that animal's
life when you give them
the efas along with the other 90
essential nutrients don't forget the
other 97 nutrients so that yeah I always
get nervous when we talk about a
nutrient and people say oh okay
um I'll just you know
give my dog some chicken breasts and
some efas no that's not going to work
right
well and Carrie brought up a very good
point
um in regards to you know pets and being
scratchy and itchy that the Vets will
sell you a hundred dollar a month shop
allergy shot for that
we're just changing their diet
it
takes adding the essential nutrients
it's kind of like
um are you going to put
dirt from Texas in your car you're gonna
put it all in your car
I'll stick with oil are you going to
wash your car twice a week or put oil in
your car
I'll put oil in my car well there you go
same principle is true with ourselves
and our pets and our kids and our loved
ones and
yes I agree and John says doc needs to
do a book for Animals well John guess
what
we've got this Exotic Animal book that
doc originally published was it 1982
19.
something like that from the Smithsonian
and we're looking at a reprint yeah
we're working on a reprint right now as
we speak
that's going to be exciting and folks
it's not going to be twenty five
thousand dollars that'll be much cheaper
at least 24 999 no foreign
that you're working on
there's four others in the pipeline
yep you are a very very busy man very
busy man well let's go to
let's see as we're going through
questions
um okay so Debbie has a question about
kiwi now kiwi is a 27 year old Amazon
parrot
and kiwi has started scratching at his
eye
and it looks like there is a cataract
forming
what would you recommend for kiwi Dr
Wallach
he's about 15 ounces so just under a
pound
okay let me put an ounce of the liquid
plant minerals
in in Psych six ounces of water and keep
that parrots little water
water thing for the parrot okay for
those minerals
um because they require a lot of
minerals
and where they say why aren't parrots
all over the world well they live in
certain places because they have all the
minerals in the soil that parents need
that's why they're not found universally
all over the world even though the
temperatures okay with them but they
don't have the nutrients in the soil so
you have to provide all the nutrients
those parrots need
okay whether it's a parakeet you know or
a giant parrot okay or something like
that
um they do need those nutrients and so
one of the easiest ways to do it is just
put the liquid plant minerals which has
78 minerals in it put an ounce of that
and say four or five or six ounces of
water and just keep that little water
dish in their cage full of that okay but
I would also throw some arthrodex in
because they'll lick it they'll lick
that orthodox
because they they out in the wild they
will go to all of these
um places that the animals go to the
Salt Licks and the parrots will go there
and they'll actually lick the salt
because the salt has more than sodium
chloride and it also has other minerals
because the salt came from an ocean that
was there some time when the ocean
went away all the minerals and the salt
combined to form
these rocks in the Salt Lick and so the
animals go there far and they're they're
licking the salt but they're also
getting all these other minerals
so doctor we're like okay
when I had chickens and I had more than
just a dozen backyard chickens we used
the granule minerals
and we would mix it into their food
now birds have a craw
and I think I haven't studied the
anatomy of every bird but I think
almost every bird has a crawl right and
that helps to break down the food so if
the men if they're eating the granule
minerals and that gets into the craw
then it's absorbing into their digestive
system
and we had strong shelled eggs they were
bright in color
it was the flavor was just totally
wonderful
so is that okay to do using this well
yeah I mean it's been well people have
been doing that forever
um again
um you had
a place where you would put all of your
table scraps and quote garbage unquote
um and put them into a pile in a hole in
the backyard and the chickens would come
and eat some the turkeys would come and
eat some the rabbits would come and eat
some and even the cows and horses would
come and eat some and it's one of those
things where
um it's a waste to just burn that stuff
because it has nutritional value in it
and animals are constantly looking for
that nutritional value because hey may
only have five minerals in it
and they have pica they have their
bodies telling them you need to be
eating more stuff because you're not
getting enough minerals and so that's
why horses chew on the top rail
of a fence or there are there uh stall
in the barn what do they call that one
of horseshoes on the top rail
Pike it's cribbing cribbing because okay
because of Pica why do they call it
cribbing
well I know babies used to chew on the
side of the crib yes when babies are
deficient minerals they chew on the top
rail in the crib and so they call that
cribbing and so when horses do the same
thing they called it the same thing
yeah and it was pretty sad when they
were chewing on the side of the crib
with lead-based paint
oh yeah there were consequences
and so and of course some people got it
and they knew they needed nutrients and
some people didn't get it unfortunately
a lot of the medical doctors didn't get
it
oh you got to tie up the kid because
they're trying to chew on the top of
their of their crib well
is they're telling you something
just tied up the kids doctor to solve
the problem that's right
that's right well talking about kids Dr
Wallach I do not want to miss this
question that Dan has okay
um so Dan go ahead and unmute yourself
and if you're able to come on camera
that would be fabulous as well now this
kid is this a goat kid or is this a
human kid I'm gonna say this is an a
newborn baby boy
okay that's right
so my my nephew had a couple of twins
born about 11 days ago
and the baby came premature two or three
weeks
they um had a little trouble standing at
normal body temperature that resolved
itself
they've been an intensive care the whole
time
and they caught a rhinovirus and I think
they're doing pretty good they're
getting ready to come home the next
couple of days
and one of the babies
had a bloody uh stool yesterday
and he has been diagnosed as NEC
so they put him on some antibiotic
yesterday
stop what is NEC
I have no idea it's just something was
texted to me above my nephew
so okay they took an x-ray and he's got
inflammation of the lower intestine
okay is he being breastfed or to give me
a bottle of milk
I know that they've been getting bottle
fed but as far as the breastfeeding I'm
not sure they're 100 miles away from
where I live yes okay and so yeah um if
it's being breastfed
um the mother can be eating gluten and
the gluten is being passed on to the
baby
okay and so right
we need more information here but again
um these these babies
um can be getting
the 90th Century nutrients okay in the
form of uh you go ahead we have what we
call kids toddy to kids tiny it's a
liquid formula for newborn babies it's
called kids Toddy and the the label on
the back tells you how much to give it
per pound of body weight kind of thing
okay and I would also use the same label
dosage for Cherry mins you want to add
that to the to these kids Toddy and then
as we were talking about earlier don't
forget the efas
don't forget the efas and so newborn
babies I would give that a kid
um one EFA a day go ahead and puncture
the EFA and squirt that liquid EFA into
the kids toddy
and if the mother is breastfeeding the
babies then the kids toddy could be
given uh one meal a day okay sure uh if
the mother is not breastfeeding the baby
the baby can be getting the kids toddy
for you know along with something like
Similac a complete Similac we've sued
them uh in in the courts and in 2000 see
here
they gave us you know sort of
permission to put nutrients into baby
Farmers but then by 2000
uh I think it's 2016.
um they've been put in there permanently
I think it's 2016. look it up here
um I believe that's correct and Dr
Wallach NEC is
necrotizing intro colitis a serious
gastrointestinal problem yeah that's a
gluten problem that mostly affects
premature babies
okay yeah they're being fed something
with gluten either breast milk or some
formula that has gluten in it
okay so formula is going to have gluten
in them too oh yeah
wow
so do you think the doctors would know
what kind of a formula would be
gluten-free no
darn doctors don't know anything about
nutrition
that's why they have one of the shortest
lifespans of any human
you want to go to the book rare earth
spin cures and I think it's chapter 11
goes into longevity
and of course the people with the
shortest lifespan in America are doctors
amazing
so I don't know how long it would take
to order these supplements and have them
come is there a way to get these kind of
things to you like the pharmacy
no what you do is you ask them to be
shipped overnight
okay
all right yeah yeah there's nothing like
there's nothing like kids tidy on the
market
okay okay
TDI or you can get
cardi t-o-d-d-y
ddy like a hot toddy like a hot toddy
okay but you know you can you can go get
the uh symbol act and Enfamil and stuff
like that
um we sued them uh we petitioned them we
sued them we petitioned them and of
course
um uh you can see here uh
and so when we
we're successful
in getting these nutrients into the baby
formulas I'm looking for my piece of
paper here
okay it's just about one completely away
didn't it oh here here we go yes and so
anyway uh it's one of those things where
um and it's like 2000 2016.
that the the
FDA forced him to put it in baby finals
we forced them I mean we were
petitioning and suing them for like 25
years
to get that done and doctors resisted
all those nutrients are poisonous for
babies that's how much they know about
nutrition
amazing
okay well I appreciate all the
information uh
one one quick personal question I don't
know if you have time to answer it what
are your thoughts about people drinking
water out of bottled waters like the 16
ounce bottle Waters is that a risk of
plastic okay well that's what I use to
make my
liquid supplements I put all my powders
and everything in it
because I you know I'm in the car I'm in
airplanes and stuff like that you know I
can't depend on a well in my backyard
kind of stuff and so I do use
um water in a bottle
I'll drink I'll drink a third of it and
then I put all my powders in there and
shake it up and then use that twice a
day
but I've got uh really dry skin and
somebody told me that sometimes the the
tap water's got the chlorine that can
aggravate the dry skin okay have you
ever heard of the science of crapola
yes I am okay if you have dry skin the
odds are you're if you're missing
essential fatty acids and zinc and all
kinds of other stuff
right the odds are you're eating gluten
so you're not absorbing things even if
they were in your diet or Sullivan
program
right the only people who are not
sensitive to gluten are dead people
well you do not want to be one of those
which one of your books would you
recommend I read to find out the Good
Foods deep because if I stopped eating
uh bread and cereals I don't know what I
would eat okay okay we have a book
called Dr Walsh cooking without the bad
foods it's 300 pages of gluten-free
recipes
doctor always cooking without the bad
foods
okay and then of course the book
epigenetics the book rare Earthman cures
the book
um uh Hell's Kitchen
all those are
essential information
all right
well thank you for your time today okay
well thank you for calling in sir
thank you bye-bye bye all right thank
you Dan
Dr Wallach let's go to the next tan that
is up I think Joe had another question
Joe go ahead and ask your question
hello hello sorry yes um Dr Wallach I
just wanted to Circle back
um I had talked to you about Swayze the
11 year old Chinese crested um Powder
Puff that had a sarcoma tumor you
suggested the plant minerals to rub on
him will that also help with the tumor
or just with his eating and is the tumor
pretty much no no no no no it's for his
immune system
okay
for immune system do you think his body
can reabsorb that tumor well we'll find
out won't we okay so that's the only
recommendation I wanted to make sure
um
there's no other way to get that kind of
nutrition into them if you're not eating
well and all that kind of stuff is to
rub it on their belly rub it on their
back
but you got to get the Liquid minerals
into them okay that's great and then um
if it's okay I do have a little question
for me
um okay your mammal go ahead oh yeah
yeah I'm a mammal so I'm 56 5 8 137
pounds
um you know I have Hashimoto's Lyme
disease whatever
um but the thing that I'm working on
right now is I have really bad eye
floaters and my vision is not good even
though when I go to the doctors my glass
prescription does not change
um I'm gluten-free dairy free not dairy
free right now actually
um
floaters are the equivalent of dandruff
okay they're the same issue as dandruff
you're missing something that's required
to maintain the Integrity of your retina
the lining of the eye
and so you're getting dandruff inside
your eye
you get the picture
Okay so
um 138 pounds
uh you're right at that cusp but you may
have some early warning stuff going on
here do you have any rain in your ears
no
how many times a night you wake up to
urinate
none okay good uh do you have any other
skin problems any eczema dermatitis or
psoriasis
no okay uh do you have any constipation
or diarrhea
um occasional constipation I usually
have two or three stools a day so
okay what about um have a pressure
diabetes
no um actually on the functional Med
side I was pre-diabetic
okay
and then anything going on with your
lungs any asthma bronchitis COPD
anything like that
no okay in your irregular heartbeat uh
afib your high heart rates low slow
heart rate
no okay all right
um well the the floaters in your eyes
are kind of like the red warning light
on your car dashboard
okay they're not hurting it but they're
telling you there's something missing
someplace okay
and so what you want to do is ramp up on
your nutrients so for a while I go with
two healthy abandoned heart paths for
months two healthy brain and heart
pasture months photos everything twice a
day I get two bottles of MSM should take
three at breakfast unless you dinner
time
I would get the occupative and take
three of those three times a day will be
three bottles of oxygen too because
they're little bottles okay
um but also take the vitamin D three two
bottles a month and take three of those
twice a day
and then the ultimate daily classic
tablets get two bottles of that so you
take three twice a day they're going to
support all the daily classic tablets
are going to support healthy blood flow
through blocked arteries in the eye and
the heart and the brain and every place
else
and so then call me
um and say two weeks and four weeks and
six weeks after you start this and again
don't stay away from all the bad stuff
no fried foods no processed meat so oils
or glutens and we put around those so
sugar no carbon drinks and then you know
we'll kind of know what's going on okay
okay so I have to ask should I ignore
all my food tested allergies then with
some of these because some of the stuff
I'm allergic to that are in the hearthy
brain and health pack I can't have flax
seeds and
um some other items that are in there so
should I just ignore that and kind of
just go down this path um okay what
symptoms are you getting from eating
flax seeds
um I don't know I have flushing like
extreme flushing if I eat something like
popcorn um air pop popcorn I have an
allergy to that and I have all over body
aches when I eat that okay I'll stay
away from popcorn yeah so but I have a
lot of allergies and a lot of the pro
some of the products that you're
recommending have that in there so um
okay so we don't have popcorn in our
products no you don't so there's just
flaxseed and some of the fish oils that
I can't do
so okay well
um what I want you to do is
um let's see here uh start out slow
you know just do it one meal
a week and then no problem go to two
meals a week say Tuesday and Thursday
and go for a week and no problem then
you go three meals a week Monday
Wednesday Friday okay kind of slowly get
up to it
as opposed to just taking all at once
okay
okay you're talking about taking the
products one meal a week with the
products
yeah to start with okay and then after
after a week you go to
you know two days a week and after two
weeks you go two three days a week okay
you know take take a month or five or
six weeks to get it up every day
okay
thank you okay all right thank you Joe
great questions
yep um it's a very common issue
yeah and I think keeping a food diary
and really paying attention to what our
body says to us and how it reacts
um because it's testing can be so
inconcisive depending on what we ate
yesterday yeah yeah exactly it's
impersonal testing is impersonal
so so to paying attention to how our
body reacts and keeping a food diary
is that what you think might be the best
way to go doc yeah and you know love
yourself and just take a little bit at a
time or remove bad things a little bit
at a time don't cold turkey either
direction
all right well let's go to the next hand
that is up and
we have Susan Susan go ahead and unmute
yourself you're on live with Dr Wallach
hi um thank you I have I'm feeding two
stray cats and ones
um was diagnosed with FIV
the feline immunodeficiency virus and
I'm assuming the other one has it too
because he acts the same after the two
were in a fight
at this point so I I don't have a lot of
information I I think the one that was
diagnosed uh they guessed him to be four
two years ago so he'd be six now how
much do they weigh
um I don't have an accurate I would I
would guess
um
seven to nine pounds okay standard size
cat adult cat okay yeah so they should
each get a half a scoop of arthro decks
in their food
and I would give them a good brand of
canned cat food with vitamins and
minerals added to it as opposed to just
some tuna fish or something like that
okay
maybe a canned cat food with vitamins
minerals in it
and then
okay and then add the archered X
okay if they weigh
uh
10 10 12 pounds
that's a half a scoop of arthrit X
because they weighed 15 pounds it's a
full scoop of arthritics okay
okay I'll try to get away
uh one started
um I mean he holds his head low uh and
his tongue's hanging out
he also has an eye infection mm-hmm
okay well it could have a sore throat
and that's you know because the eye
infection uh could have obviously
approached us as a skull squeezing the
optic nerve and the ninth cranial nerve
he lost a pharyngeal nerve in his throat
and so there's all kinds of
possibilities there but uh okay but we
do have
um
occupative you take a couple of those
and put them in the cat's food okay
don't forget the efas for cats I like
the EFA pluses because they're made from
fish oils
okay
all righty so the the trick is I am
feeding them
top quality food it's gluten-free
um good and uh you know I even want the
the better race
animals except for it's a little uh the
cost is is a bit much so but it's so
it's painful when they don't eat it all
so I'm concerned about how to how to get
this um
uh the arthrodex you can put it on your
channel don't throw it away if they're
not gonna you eat it
I could trouble use it for sure all
right oh good well and then speaking of
me when you say two healthy brain and
heart packs I have the the powdered kit
all right you mean the what it says on
here one scoop of each or to double that
no what you want to do uh Health
debating heart pack is a pack it's a set
it's got a bunch of stuff in it yeah
okay it's not just the it's not just the
BTT 2.0 BTT 2.0 is part of the health
abandon hard pack but it has all these
other products in there
okay so I say the hell the Brainerd
heart pack it's a pack
that you get all this stuff in
and when he says two per month that's
two doses per day so on that pack one
dose would be one scoop of the Beyond
Tangy Tangerine one scoop of the osteofx
three of the EFA plus if it's the brain
and heart pack you're looking at three
twice a day of the ultimate EFA and then
three selenium
a day so if you're doing two packs per
month you're gonna double that
okay and if I'm doing like once one
scoop of the tangerine
definitely Two Scoops you need to do
yeah you're not you're not getting
everything if that's all you're taking
that's maybe my value because I have
skin issues and at first I was starting
to see a little Improvement and then at
this level down how many nutrients does
your skin need
how many what did you say how many
nutrients does your skin needed oh the
90. yeah so don't just take one yeah
yeah oh no yeah well I'm I meant to take
the whole package one package yeah
and make sure you're taking those efas
people don't realize the importance of
the essential fatty acids the omega-3 6
and 9. and if I if I miss you know it's
three times a day I find I forget at
least one time can you double up or you
just ignore it like if you miss you too
at night no no just go ahead and take
um one dose of everything
twice a day
one dose of breakfast one dose of dinner
okay but like the selenium uh is three
times a day if I forget it the middle of
the day do I take two at night or no
just don't forget the next day okay
to work on the memory here
all right so that's why you want that's
why you want to have a checklist that's
why Pilots when they get an airplane
they have a checklist
so don't forget anything
yeah good plan good plan all right thank
you with the cats okay and me all right
thank you Susan
so Dr Wallach
even if you take
for selenium perhaps
you have one for breakfast you makes you
miss your lunch dose
you can have two at dinner right yeah if
you're taking two dinner and one at
breakfast for one day a week that's fine
but you know if you're doubling up and
tripling up every day
um there might be an issue
okay now let's go to pets and not
knowing exactly how much like these
these wild feline
um that she's feeding not knowing
exactly how much they weigh if we did a
scoop
and it was more than what is needed per
weight is that going to hurt them no
okay because the Azure you're not going
to give it enough nutrients for a 300
pound
lion
well right
and I know for us when we're nutrient
deficient it takes a little bit extra to
help fill that efficiency right catch up
that's right
so all right thank you so much and then
as far as essential fatty acids so we
had a question what's the difference
between the EFA plus and the ultimate
EFA
go ahead no go ahead well I was going to
say they both contain Omega 3 6 and 9.
they're just in different forms
so where the EFA plus is more of the
omega-3 and like Dr Wallach said
primarily primarily fish oil the
Ultimate Omega is coming also from flax
and borage oil
so you're getting a nice combination and
balance of the different essential fatty
acids from different food sources
so and not all efas are created equal
yeah it's just always best to get two or
three or four or five different
sources you know plants and animals and
seeds and all that kind of stuff
all right
so great questions today I'm saying yeah
it's good for all the information that
we're sharing John wants to know if you
have a book specifically for
young couples
before getting pregnant during pregnancy
and then during your breastfeeding so
there you go doc book number five coming
your way
we'll put it on the list
and let's go to HF HF I saw your hand
here did you go away
um oh I don't see that they have
audio connected
um but HF had a question in the comments
that I'm seeing here is alkaline water
okay
and the answer is no
and the reason stomach or your stomach
uh has to be an acid environment for the
stomach acid to work to be able to
digest food to be able to absorb
minerals
the last thing you want to do
because of that supply of being what
happened it'll be the last thing you do
if you alkalize your stomach
you don't want to do that
so you want to make if you have a couple
of cases of alkaline water give it to
your doctor
all right well HF did you have another
question in regard or outside of that
one go ahead and unmute yourself if you
did oh thank you so much Rebecca
um thank you for answering those
questions but is it three air base plus
for the dosage when you have the heart
brain and heart pack or is it one three
I'm I'm a little unclear on that though
but depends on how much you weigh
I'm at 150 150 yeah I'll be three efas
um and three EFA pluses twice a day
three phase in the morning and three
phase in the evening that's correct can
three EFA plus those in the morning and
threefa plus there's an evening because
one comes from seeds the other one comes
from fish liver oil thank you sir God
bless thank you Rebecca you're very
welcome
now Mark has a question
um can we or animals get enough EFA from
salmon if we eat it twice a week
um not from eating just the salmon flesh
because the efas are coming from the
liver right the liver that's correct
yeah I think I think it's easier to
swallow if you have it in a soft gel
capsule personally but that's just me
um okay
so we have another human question from
Shantae Shantae did you want to come on
um she has a client that's 80 years old
female
diagnosed with vestibular
and that's all the information she had
so I don't know Shantae okay well
vestibular that sounds like middle ear
stuff got to be something going on with
balance and tinnitus ringing in the ears
80 years old that all makes sense
okay so we don't know what she weighs
but for 100 pounds of body weight you
need one healthy branded heart attack
um
see her two two bottles of the MSM so
you take three breakfast fruit lunch at
dinner collagen peptides a scoop with
breakfast scoop and dinner
um I've seen the drink and then
um also needs the vitamin D3 through
those twice a day needs the
um collagen peptides I think I said that
collagen peptides a scoop of breakfast
scoop of dinner
and don't forget the ultimate daily
classic tapestry twice a day for blood
flow
and even I've had people 100 510 years
old have all these terrible stuff going
on with dizziness balance problems
raining in the ears and stuff going on
of all kinds maybe 15 20 different
problems and we get them on this program
and within two to six weeks it all goes
away
we have a book and a CD in fact you're
my co-author on the CD it's all in your
head
um so the book of the CD it's on your
head if you buy them together you get a
discount if you buy them a week apart
you have to pay the full price so I'd
get the set if it's all in your head the
book and the CD it covers 37 different
diseases including the vestibular
um because you're talking about the
um ringing in the ears and balance and
dizziness and all that kind of stuff
Bell's Palsy try General neuralgia
getting up five times a night to go to
the urinate and all those kind of things
all cause biology approach to Cisco
the formula for what to take for the
osteopostale is in the book
so if you don't hear what we have to say
or didn't it was not quick enough to
write it down it'll the formula is in
the book
it's on your head so you have access to
that as long as you have the book you
have access to the formula
thank you very much you bet all right
thank you Shantae
um great question now John made a
comment Dr Wallach he said a flat flock
of parrots stripped his Apricot Tree
they didn't eat the fruit they broke
open the stones and just ate the seeds
so is it because if there's minerals
within the seeds that they were missing
that they
word smelling or what
okay well a lot of birds eat seeds
because they don't like sweet fleshy
things
okay because they've learned if they eat
sweet plushy things they got all that
juice around their face and the flies
come and jump on them and all that kind
of stuff and and so they're interested
in the seeds which have
um very dense nutrition in it whereas
the sugary flesh of the fruit doesn't
okay
and
I I guess God put that whole Instinct in
them that
forget the flesh just go for the seed
that's right
there are seed eaters seed eaters
um since we are on humans Carrie has a
question so
um
she what do you recommend for people who
have already had knee replacement her
dad's friend who is six foot tall
probably 175 pounds
83 years old had one knee replaced that
went fine now having a harder time
healing from the second the wife has had
one replaced as well and they're not
coming to my to her wedding because they
can't travel and they were World
Travelers
so what would you recommend for somebody
that's already had knee replacement doc
because
don't go back to the same doctor
yeah don't go to the same doctor but the
knee replacement didn't correct the
whole cause that they needed that's
correct that's correct in other words if
you have for instance uh your engine's
heating up because you're too corn slow
and oil and you change your tires that
help you
no
okay so they need a hair analysis let's
find out what's going on there
we need to see all the records all their
blood tests but I guarantee they didn't
get a hair analysis get a hold of that
book rare herzmann cures chapter 10 and
11 page 272. get that hair analysis
that's going to help enormously in great
detail what needs to be done okay
okay and you can get rare earth
forbidden cures on our website ask that
live.com and there is a link there that
you can get the book
um and as Dr Wallach said in chapter 10
it has all the information you need in
order to get a hair analysis and Dr
Wallach the hair analysis is a hundred
bucks it's been a hundred bucks since
this book was last
published Wichita to what 10 11
different reprints
nine it's on the ninth printing so when
we print it again it's going to be the
10th printing
and the price is still 100 bucks folks
since it was last printed in 2018. yeah
and you get two charts you get one chart
for these essential minerals you get a
second charge for toxic metals like lead
and mercury and uranium and other stuff
like that and so it's really really very
useful I have so many people who said oh
yeah you know I was in the military for
10 years for 20 years and I have all
these chemicals from the weapons we do a
hair analysis on them they don't have
any of those
um
dangerous chemicals is shocking to them
but what they did have was nutritional
deficiencies causing all their symptoms
there you go there you go
um and Dr Wallach you first published
this in 1994.
yes that's correct information is still
relevant today oh well gravity's still
true today as it was when the Old
Testament was written
3500 years ago yes for certain things
that are going to be the same forever uh
the Earth orbits the Sun
in the beginning people thought that the
sun orbited the Earth
they also thought it was flat that's
correct
so
I'm glad that it's not flat it's not
that I've done a whole lot of traveling
I want to be a world traveler and I plan
on keeping my knees healthy to do so
um HF has another question and she did
ask it in the chat here but go ahead and
unmute yourself if you would please
thank you so much thank you so much I
have a customer who has been dealing
with any knee issue
has been taking the the the protocol but
finds that at night time when he lays
down he's been doing a lot of
information at night time when he lays
down the information goes down then he's
fine wakes up in the morning
beneath the ankle the feet is back
swollen can you give an explanation for
that yeah so basically this this guy's
got osteoporosis of the skull
uh squeezing
the spinal cord and so he's got what's
called peripheral neuropathies all this
stuff going on down in in the back and
the hips and the knees and and so forth
these are the sort of guys that wake up
three four five six eight ten times a
night to urinate these are the guys that
like you say when they lay in a certain
position the pain goes away but in the
morning everything's all swollen and
painful when they get up out of bed but
it has to do with the skull squeezing
the spinal cord as the skull is coming
out of the back of the skull most people
don't realize that but your spinal cord
is made in the brain comes out of the
back of the skull through a hole called
the foramen magnum which is Latin for
big hole
and it causes you know 20 or 30
different diseases and you go to 20 30
different Specialists and doctors and
surgeries and knee Replacements and hip
replacements but all the problem is
really up in the skull
so is so what would be specific for that
it's called
the healthy brain and heart pack MSM
collagen peptides
Beyond OSU FX vitamin D3
foreign
ligaments and tendons in the skull and
then the vertebrae it all goes away
thank you doc thank you so much thank
you thank you Rebecca you're welcome
so folks it all works together the whole
system we weren't
built in just a part here A Part here
that works on its own without the
interaction of the other parts I mean
our circulatory system feeds every
single
Square
even less than millimeter of the body
the nutrients that the body needs at the
cellular level
so we want to make sure that we keep our
circulation that's blood and the
lymphatic circulation flowing throughout
our body so that we're not getting that
congestion we're not getting those blood
clots we're not
cutting off nutrients from different
parts of our body because we don't have
good circulation
so everything works together making sure
that you're getting your 90 essential
nutrients every day if you've got things
going on it is going to take some extra
stuff
in order to replenish or correct
deficiencies
and one thing that Dr Wallach found in
all of his research on animals is it
correlates into the human world also
especially when we're looking at mammal
to mammal
deficiencies were mammals had specific
conditions deficiencies for humans had a
lot of those same
conditions of poor health
so being intentional making sure that
we're getting the nutrients that our
body needs to function as a whole
is so important we don't want to
underestimate the importance of
how much the body needs we are not
simple organisms folks
but Health can be simple
when you've got the right raw
ingredients going in
so Dr Wallach I think it's hot where
you're at yeah it's very hot
it's like 82 degrees right now
82 degrees and probably not a whole lot
of air circulation I got fans going but
it's just moving the air around there
you go well that keeps you've gotta you
know the whole whole natural swamp
cooler thing going on you're sweating
get some air flowing helps cool you off
and make sure that you're drinking lots
of fluid with minerals because that
sweat is not just water it's a rebound
minerals rebound rebound yes I love the
powdered rebound for those of you who
are looking at rebound as just kind of
an energy drink I love the powder
because it only has eight and a half
grams of sugar where they can not only
have do you have to open it the day
before to let the carbonation you know
go away it also has more sugar but the
powder has more nutrients Dr Wallach so
convenience
or your
you get more
I'll take more
just personally but I we're coming up to
the end
and
I am so thankful for my co-hosts
I just want to put them up here
and they are phenomenal we can't thank
them enough they kept the chat rolling
they were answering questions you know
some simple questions that were coming
through they were putting up the answers
there for them and thank you for getting
jonty up there hello jaunty and I want
to do a special thank you for Phyllis
also who is part of our team that was
providing information including
the number that people can call to speak
with Dr Wallach on the radio
during the Dead Doctors Don't Lie radio
show
so if you have somebody that is not into
Zoom
and getting on Via Zoom or this time
does not work for them then if you go to
ksco 1080 no is it ksco.com
and you will find under the shows Dead
Doctors Don't Lie and you will find the
information there that they can call
into the radio show Monday through
Friday
from noon to 1 Pacific time
and if you are listening and you want
the phone number real quick it's
888-379-2552 so the best time to call is
early
if you want to get into the program call
as close to noon is absolutely possible
because the phone lines do start to fill
up and you want to make sure that you
are it's like raising your hand
first one there we call on first right
so as you're getting into that call line
up make sure that you um call in early
and have the opportunity to speak with
Dr Wallach
um on the radio so you're more than
welcome to share that with others but
again if you were sent to this program
or any program
by somebody specific get back with the
person that shared that program with you
they cared enough to take the time to
share this information with you and
where it is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician we are
not here to diagnose cure our products
do not do any of that stuff
but your body
was divinely created that when it's
given the raw ingredients that it needs
it can do some amazing stuff folks
you have been watching ask that live
thank you so much for joining us with
all of your animal questions I think
we're going to be doing this once a
month aren't we jaunty
um where we're gonna have on the first
Friday ask that live of the month so
make sure you tell your friends
um for those of you who are part of our
youngevity family
share this program with others because
this is a tool that's put together to
help you get information out to your
friends and family and Community without
it just coming from you we've got the
man himself the man that's been doing
the research who has written the books
so many books already written already
published and more to come folks so stay
tuned we're so excited
hope you all have a fabulous September
bye for now
am I thank you